[Music]
it's Christian bells gonna play our
villain which is gonna be fantastic yeah
it's gonna be good
Tessa Thompson is spilling some brand
new secrets about Thor love and thunder
and only et has the exclusive details we
cannot wait to finally watch Valkyrie
come back into our lives for love and
thunder what can you give us you have
you read the script yet head yeah I've
read the script I can't tell you much
but lots of exciting text messages
exchanged between Natalie and I we're
gonna have fun we're gonna have fun you
know Tyga's writing directing some
familiar faces some new people into the
mix Christian Belle's gonna play our
villain which is going to be fantastic
welcome back everyone
it's Charley big surprise Tessa Thompson
just confirmed that Christian Bale will
be the main villain of Thor for love and
thunders we got to break it down there's
a bunch of Marvel phase 4 Easter eggs we
know a little bit about the character
he's playing so if you're new to my
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the videos we're doing a movie ticket
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your biggest
theory about who Christian Bale is
playing on the video we'll just do this
top 5 style starting with number 5 if
you don't know what's going on here
Tessa Thompson is in Westworld season 3
so she was doing the premiere of that
while she was answering questions about
Thor for love and thunder because we're
gonna get ready to shoot that pretty
soon that's why all this Christian Bale
talk has been happening because they've
been locking down their cast they
already know most of the characters that
were coming back because a lot of them
are pre-existing MCU characters like
Tessa Thompson says a lot of familiar
faces coming back with a couple new ones
obviously Christian Bale being one of
the new faces I'll talk about the other
characters that are coming back in a
second because most of you probably have
a pretty good idea of which Thor
characters come back they're the same
ones that come back in every single Thor
movie with a couple twists this time
because of what's going on with Loki
it took you long enough
I had to pick up the key the casting
description for Christian Bale's
character just says he's an
intergalactic villain and based on his
history with Marvel and big franchises
like this it rules out a couple picks
for who the main villains going to be so
we'll just go down the list and cover
all the things Marvel has already
confirmed about Thor 4 I've seen some of
your pie-in-the-sky wishes for who he
would be so number 4 a lot of you have
asked me about Adam warlock in beta ray
bill because we know from the guardians
of the galaxy to post-credit scene that
in true comic book fashion Adam warlock
will start out as a villain he's being
hatched by the sovereign to destroy the
guardians of the galaxy they're arguably
antagonist villains in the MCU right now
his basic comic book arc was he was
created to be this space Jesus villain
by an alien race then turned against his
masters became a good character until he
wasn't again because of his evil half
the mages taking control of his body
kind of like a Hulk versus banner
situation with a very religious themed
space-based character they haven't said
anything about doing the mages in the
MCU just Adam warlock and even though
Christian Bale would be an amazing mages
regardless James Gunn probably wouldn't
let Tyga steal the character from him
before he has a chance to use a version
of Adam warlock in guardians of the
galaxy 3 in the reason why Christian
Bale probably isn't beta ray bill even
though that would also be really cool is
because even though beta ray bill and
Thor fought several times in the comics
in the eighties beta ray bill during
thor ragnarok he was originally supposed
to be in that movie in the contest of
Champions his face is on the
grandmasters Tower beta ray bill is a
pretty big character that it sounds like
they're gonna want to bring back every
once in a while and he is mostly a
motion-capture performance meaning you
would not be able to see christian
bale's face and you just know that
marvel is thirsty to put christian
bale's face on a Thor 4 poster and say
give us all your money because we put
Batman in our movie so number 3 a lot of
the Marvel comic book people over at the
publishing side of things wanted to play
Daario agar the head of Roxon who's a
Minotaur who sold his soul to literally
gain the power of a Minotaur he can turn
into a physically
giant Minotaur we also just saw Roxon
showing up on the set of the Loki TV
series and we know that Loki from that
series is gonna crossover with Thor for
so it sounds like Roxon stuff is
happening during Marvel phase four which
means that eventually they'd have to do
the Daario Agger Minotaur character but
the rest of the internet seems convinced
that he should be playing a version of
Gore the god butcher because he's one of
the few characters that could hand Thor
his ass and if you were gonna be in a
Thor movie if you're gonna be a threat
you have to be able to spank Thor in
some way and gore is just one of the few
characters that can do that pretty
easily with the necro sword whether or
not they would use something like that
in a Marvel movie because they kind of
did that with hello's powers even though
technically they didn't call it the
necro sword you may remember that
Christian Bale has said many times in
the last 10 years since he's been
playing Batman even before he played
Batman that he had no interest in
working with Marvel and hadn't even
watched superhero movies outside of the
Christopher Reeve Superman movies in his
own Batman Dark Knight trilogy movies in
fact he hasn't even watched all three of
his Batman movies just because there was
a tragedy that happened during the
premieres of one of those that just made
it too hard for him to go back and watch
it after the fact so what kind of black
magic did Kevin Feige in tyka performed
to convince Christian Bale to be in a
big Marvel movie like this usually in
situations like this with big big actors
like Cate Blanchet is a good example is
they offer them a one-off role it's a
really big main role they're gonna be
featured heavily they'll get to have a
lot of fun and do something that they've
never done before play a big comic book
villain after he got done playing one of
the biggest most iconic comic book
heroes you either die a hero or you live
long enough to see yourself become the
villain so regardless of who he's
playing I just think that Christian Bale
is gonna be doing Thor 4 and he won't
come back for any more movies after that
another really good example is how Ryan
Reynolds got Brad Pitt to do Vanisher in
Deadpool 2 Brad Pitt's kids were huge
Deadpool fans so it's also possible
Christian Bale's kids really liked the
Marvel movies so number 2 what's the
basic plot of the movie well they
explained a little bit of this back at
comic-con Taika Waititi said that while
they were making thor ragnarok he was
reading mighty thor and thought that it
would make for a good movie at least the
concept of the movie they're not gonna
do the exact Mighty Thor a comic book he
said he wasn't totally
old on the Jane Foster cancer storyline
so they might not do that part but if
Christian Bale is playing a version of
Gore the god butcher temporarily
sidelining Chris Hemsworth or like he
did in the comics after going after all
the gods around the universe it would
create the need for another Thor but you
also have Loki coming from an alternate
reality so Loki could also be
responsible through some mischief
time-travel in alternate realities for
bringing about another version of
Mjolnir or an alternate reality version
of Jane Foster Thor what I'm hoping
though is they also include beta ray
bill and then he goes on to star in
other space-based movies because it
sounds like Marvel a cosmic universe is
spinning up in a really big way because
now Nick Fury is on the sword Space
Station as of the spider-man far from
home post-credit scenes we know because
of the Wanda vision series on Disney
Plus they're doing sword from the comics
so it just means that a lot more space
based stuff is gonna be happening in all
the movies during Marvel phase four
number one WTF though what about four as
guardians of the galaxy what are they
gonna do with that because clearly they
were trying to set up this big quest
that he was going on with them he was
gonna have this existential crisis tried
to figure out where his place in the
galaxy was what am I supposed to do if
I'm not going to be king Thor number one
on his list should be to lose all that
weight borrowing star Lords Bowflex that
he joked about during infinity war but
guardians of the galaxy vol 3 isn't
happening till at least a year after
Thor 4 comes out so they're gonna have
to address whatever's going on with that
either at the beginning of Thor in a
short scene or he's just gonna have to
show up on a planet saying that they
dropped him off there's a couple of
funny ways that you could actually do
that without having to cast all the
guardians in the movie and spend all
that money just for the cameos before we
found out that they were gonna make Thor
4 I was actually hoping that they would
just turn a guardians of the galaxy vol
3 into as guardians of the galaxy and
that would be our next Thor movie and
they would just do a Thor Ragnarok style
crossover movie should fight one another
for the honour of leadership sounds fair
it's not necessary it's not okay
I got some blasters unless you guys want
to use knives oh yes please use knives
not anchored but the really cool news is
a Chris Hemsworth did say that he wanted
to continue being Thor beyond Thor four
which means him coming back during
Avengers five but also because it's
gonna be a couple years before that
happens you have a guardians of the
galaxy three movie that Thor can briefly
crossover into early prediction that
would also be a really easy way to put
beta ray bill on a future guardians of
the galaxy roster because if you
remember the scene at the end of
guardians of the galaxy - with the
original guardians from a long time ago
with Sylvester Stallone and all the
other characters those alien characters
are a really good example of how beta
ray bill would work perfectly on a
Guardians team just super weird and
super cool so everyone let me know in
the comments who do you think Christian
Bale is playing during Thor for the
really good news is we're finally going
to get the venom 2 trailer really soon
also more Morbius and spider-man trailer
videos they're gonna start shooting
spider-man 3 really soon - so there'll
be a lot of spider-man and venom related
stuff happening the next couple of
months
everyone click here to learn what's
going on with Hulk during Marvel phase 4
and everyone click here to learn about
the new Last of Us HBO series thank you
so much for watching everyone stay
awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]